- [Woman] Why do you curse so much,
for a guy who doesn't need to?
- Because I only believe in authenticity.
It's how I talk.
When I think about, do I
care about my employees,
it feels more like, in my
brain and my heart and my soul,
do I give a fuck about my employees
more than do I care about my employees.
That's from my brain
and heart to my mouth.
I am willing to deal
with the ramifications
of me being my full self.
- [Woman] Do you curse at home?
- A ton.
- [Woman] In front of your kids?
- Yep.
I'm just not devastated to go
into my fourth grade teacher
and Mrs. Thompson's like,
"You have a real problem."
I'm like, "What's that, Mrs. Thompson?"
"Your daughter curses."
I just don't see that as a real problem.
Me and Mrs. Thompson just don't
see the world the same way.
Again, I am the byproduct
of Mrs. Thompson telling me my whole life
that I would be a failure.
Mrs. Thompson thought that a D in science
was going to be my downfall,
just like she thinks saying
fuck is her downfall.
I don't agree.